it all began in the Bay of florianópolis
on the island of ratones Grundy stands
one of Brazil's oldest solar power
plants built by Ricardo hooda his plant
supplies the historical fortress with
electricity the professor of renewable
energy installed it 15 years ago what
has happened since then
well it's developed a lot originally
most of the installations were like this
with batteries for isolated systems
where the grid doesn't come and now it's
starting to pick up more in the grid
connected areas but this standalone
systems they are still very important
for rural areas for rural
electrification where you don't have
access to the utility grid florianópolis
on the atlantic ocean is a city with
500,000 residents almost all of whom
travel by car it's grown considerably in
the past few years and more than
anything it gets plenty of Sun light and
that's why Brazil's largest photovoltaic
plant is being set up here the one
megawatt rooftop system will crown the
building of the power generation company
Electress all part of it has already
been installed and tours for school
children are being conducted twice a
week here on the roof there are flat
silicon panels silicon is a material you
find in stones the Sun shines on them
and the light is converted into
electrical power in Brazil it's still a
matter of informing people about solar
energy the school children here are
experiencing it firsthand nine such
demonstration plants are currently being
built on the premises starting in August
dollar generating 550 kilowatts of solar
power and the rooftop units will produce
another 450 kilowatts on top a megawatt
and all oh my with absolute that means
something completely new is being
created higher levels not just for us in
electro soon as you but for all brazil
by fuzzy we're building a solar plant on
the grounds of a public corporation
that's never happened before Duda Dewey
defeats uber cool it'll be the first
large-scale solar power plant in Brazil
and we're doing this in cooperation with
the KfW per se da will ok for dubbed the
KfW Germany's Development Bank is
funding the project not as alone but as
a gift they're plowing 2.8 million euros
into it
without that money the project wouldn't
be profitable for electro salt it would
be too expensive compared to other
energy sources but that's changing
prices are tumbling in the solar sector
and solar technology is becoming cheaper
in Brazil as well and the country needs
power Brazil's economy is currently
growing by just one percent but one
percent growth requires a gigawatt of
extra power a thousand times what the
plans solar plant in florianopolis will
generate